Change Lives.
Change Organizations.
Change the World.
When we say change lives, change organizations
and change the world, we really mean it.
Stanford GSB equips students to do that.
You first have to start by changing yourself.
Students are naturally encouraged to innovate.
Broadens your perspectives on how to influence,
how to lead.
I learned to be a critical, analytical thinker.
I understand the global context of management.
At the GSB, I can use virtually the whole
world
while studying at this place. I have access
to
a lot of leaders of international organizations.
People who start their own companies, film
directors, bankers and private equity consultants.
Renowned leaders from around the world…Nobel
prize winners.
It’s really a transformational experience.
Change lives.
Change organizations.
Change the world.
I just came back from the Stanford Tsinghua
exchange program. Austria, Switzerland, Kenya,
Rwanda.
When the faculty come on these trips we can
bring that experience directly into the classroom.
It’s been inspiring, complicated, exciting.
We meet with head of marketing at Red Bull.
We’re meeting with Bay and Capital.
We’re meeting with Shanda. The best company
in China.
President Kagame, the president of Rwanda;
Daniel arap Moi, the former president of Kenya.
The minister of industry and commerce,
and lessons learned from GSB alums were amazing.
Some alumni are very warm hearted to give
us great career advice.
We have a group of alumni who have had an
incredible impact on the world,
individuals who have lived our mantra.
Change lives. Change organizations. And Change
the world.
Hoping to change all three.
I’m really interested in entrepreneurship
and innovation. Energy, clean tech space.
We’re working in tourism in Peru, private
equity, combining business and medicine.
Stanford GSB believes in the individual’s
ability to affect change.
Make a difference in the lives of, you know,
hundreds, millions of peoples.
Pursue your dream.
Dream on a world scale.
Change lives.
Change organizations.
And change the world.
>>upbeat music